[Música]
a reportero es el magacín de los grandes
reportajes de la redacción de france 24
soy armenia fernández y hoy los
llevaremos a ucrania comenzamos
el 24 de febrero de 2022 la vida de
millones de personas cambió por completo
en ucrania a dos meses de la guerra más
de cinco millones de refugiados han
buscado protección fuera de las
fronteras de su país más de un millón
retornaron y al menos el 17 por ciento
de la población tuvo que desplazarse
internamente según estimaciones de la
onu en el reportaje que verán a
continuación nuestra compañera catalina
gómez y oriol gallar hicieron un
recorrido por distintas ciudades del
oeste de ucrania para mostrar la
travesía de quienes abandonaron el país
dejando atrás toda una vida sus
pertenencias y sus familiares también
documentaron la historia de quienes se
quedaron a resistir y a combatir en un
ambiente inhumano y hostil
catalina se encuentra hoy con nosotros
desde ny pro gracias por acompañarnos
catalina hicieron un recorrido bastante
completo por el suroeste de ucrania y se
encontraron a muchas personas huyendo y
a otras aferrándose a su vida bajo el
ataque de las bombas que fue lo más
impactante entre todas estas historias
humanas que conocieron
no cada historia fue fue bastante
impactante pero en lo personal y creo
que para el resto del equipo si impacto
la cantidad de personas mayores
muchos de ellos pensionados
especialmente mujeres que habían vivido
la segunda guerra mundial que nacieron
bajo la unión soviética que vivieron
muchísimos años y que actualmente viven
en refugios en solitario tratando de
sobrevivir con la poca ayuda que les que
les queda y bueno y tratando de darse
apoyo entre todas ellas especialmente en
grandes ciudades como mykolaiv una
ciudad de 500 mil habitantes que fue un
gran bastión muy importante durante la
unión soviética o el sap orilla o en el
mismo ni pero así que fueron esas
historias de personas mayores las que
tal vez nos impactaron y obviamente los
niños pero los niños especialmente
cuando salían del país con el trauma que
les daba dejar a sus padres recordemos
que los hombros no pueden salir hombres
entre 18 y 60 años porque hay una ley
marcial
sí catalina a más de dos meses del
conflicto la guerra se convirtió en un
estilo de vida en el país cuál es el
ambiente que persiste en estos momentos
en ucrania
pues hemos regresado y apenas empezamos
a volver a ciudades que ya habíamos
visitado como dehesa o vinícola por
ejemplo en mykolaiv la situación está en
medio de la batalla está siendo atacada
constantemente porque es una ciudad
estratégica por ejemplo y no hay agua en
absoluto todo el mundo tiene que recoger
en galones llevarlo a su casa a los
baños no funcionan pero aún así las
personas que se quedaron empiezan a
reactivar su vida de aprender unas
dinámicas que hace un mes por ejemplo no
tenía hemos visto lugares abiertos
personas yendo a tomar su café hacer una
vida diaria todo esto bajo las alarmas y
los bombardeos entonces cada vez que
suena una alarma la gente ya sabe cómo
distinguir si la alarma solamente es
para el área de saint nicholas
inmediatamente van a los refugios porque
piensan que es más inminente si la
alarma es para todo el país pues ya
piensa que va para otras reacciones cada
cual ha ido aprendiendo sus dinámicas y
muchos han tomado la decisión de que por
más mal que la están pasando aquí en su
país en su casa en su familia y qué irse
solamente les traerá mayores problemas
eso nos hemos encontrado incluso con
mujeres jóvenes con hijos pequeños que
han tomado esa decisión
gracias a catalina a que la historia
[Música]
este nuevo tren que hace su arribo a la
estación urbana de sajonia es la vía de
escape de un nuevo grupo que huye de
ucrania como ha sucedido del 24 de
febrero la mayoría son madres con sus
hijos y algunas personas mayores que
todavía soportan la dureza del camino la
ley marcial impuesta por el gobierno
desde el comienzo de la guerra impide
que los hombres menores de 18 mayores de
60 años las acompañen
el padre murió estamos solas somos solo
dos chicas no tenemos más familia no
crean ya sólo nosotras
el miedo a morir queda al otro lado de
la frontera tendrán georgia se magnifica
al llegar también porque ni se quedaron
y al futuro incierto al que se enfrentan
natalia es cirujana puso a un lado su
profesión en este momento en que su
labor es más necesaria que nunca para
proteger a sus dos pequeños de siete y
cinco años
más fácil
después de tres
apenas unas cuantas personas toman el
tren que hace la ruta inversa rumbo a
ucrania una de ellas y sana un asistente
de vuelo a quien la guerra sorprendió
por fuera del país ahora regresa a
recoger a su hija ya su madre para luego
llevarlas a un lugar seguro en el oeste
del país
por teléfono madre
lloró mucho porque yo tengo más
conocimiento de lo que está pasando que
ella
una vez en la estación ucraniana de chop
aparecen los hombres que no se ven al
otro lado de la frontera
pero también las imágenes desgarradoras
que dejan las despedidas
alexander ha venido a dejar a anna su
prometida
la pareja planeaba casarse en los
próximos meses por el momento e ir a
alemania y el volver a jarquín la
segunda ciudad del país a dar apoyo a
las personas que viven bajo los
bombardeos
lo más terrible es que hay gente que
está en una situación mucho peor que la
mía ahora mismo zonas como jarquín en la
región de javier como butch a oír allí
mucha gente inocente está sufriendo
especialmente niños gente que ni
siquiera puede escapar del yugo
después de atravesar los montes cárpatos
se llega a iván no franquista
aquí no todos han querido esperar a que
termine la guerra para cumplir sus
sueños
la oficina de registro es visitada cada
día por decenas de parejas que han
decidido adelantar sus planes de boda o
que han decidido concretar una decisión
que habían aplazado como olga llevan
viven juntos hace cinco años y tienen
dos hijos
como esposa de militar considero que me
debo quedar en ucrania
y creo que todo va a estar bien
no quiero dejar mi casa e ir a otro
lugar
han conseguido que las autoridades hagan
una excepción y aceleren unas ceremonias
que generalmente deberían programarse
con meses de anticipación
la partida de iban al frente de batalla
nueva espera este es un momento marcado
por la alegría pero también por el miedo
y la tristeza
esta es la primera vez desde el comienzo
de la guerra que tengo las primeras
lágrimas
la vida como la conocían dejó de existir
para los jurar ya nos y cada uno intenta
adaptarse a la nueva realidad
bogotana es chef de profesión y desde
hace años trabaja en un restaurante
ha decidido hacer un entrenamiento
militar para estar preparada ante una
eventualidad
tengo un hijo pequeño y entendí que si
no estaba preparada para protegerlo
quién más lo iba a hacer
tengo que confiar en mis capacidades
a pesar de haber sido atacada unas
cuantas veces desde el inicio de la
guerra sigue siendo un lugar seguro para
cientos de miles de personas que han
buscado refugio en esta región del país
natalia chaplinesca lidera una red de
psicólogos avanzada de apoyo cuando
llegan a centros de recepción como éste
la mayoría de estas familias han huido
de sus casas sin nada
hablamos con quienes llegan sobre esos
miedos nos apoyamos o les ayudamos no a
quitarse el temor sino a comprenderlo y
aceptarlo quitarse de esta situación es
imposible pero saber cómo comportarse
apropiadamente es muy importante
sap orilla es el punto de llegada de
aquellos que han tenido suerte y han
podido escapar del infierno que se vive
en mario pool
en este gran almacén es dar el apoyo que
necesitan para estos primeros momentos
han a logrado ir con las mujeres de su
familia pero los hombres se quedaron
atrás su abuela sufre porque no tiene
cómo comunicarse con ellos
el 80% de la infraestructura de la
ciudad está destruida
lo que hace imposible para la gente
vivir allí
miles de personas han quedado sin casa
muchos de ellos la mayoría de ellos
se esconden en los sótanos sin das agua
ni electricidad y sin conexión a
internet
es un arte
algunas familias denuncian que la única
opción que les daban para salir era
hacia rusia este es el caso de irina que
después de días de angustia logró
encontrar la manera de llegar hasta aquí
junto con su madre y su abuela
los voluntarios que estaban allí
cuidando de nosotros nos dijeron que
solo teníamos una vía para salir de allí
y que sabía era rusia
nos decíamos que no podíamos volver a
ucrania que nuestra única salida es ruso
dones o rostov sólo rusia
este grupo de personas se organizan para
emprender el camino opuesto buscan ir a
mariupol y salvar a los suyos la mayoría
no tiene contacto con ellos desde hace
semanas julia no tiene carro gusta que
uno de estos conductores las llegadas a
la ciudad para rescatar a su madre
la última vez que me comunique con ella
fue el 4 de marzo y estaba en la casa se
escondía en un closet el refugio
antibombas estaba a 15 minutos de su
casa y por eso decidió quedarse allí
hoy no ha tenido suerte pero le han
prometido que si pueden pasarán por la
casa de su madre para saber cómo está
los autorizados son estos 50 coches solo
2 por vehículo una vez dentro de
mariupol se enfrentarán a su propia
suerte todos son conscientes del riesgo
que corren
dimitió ha logrado que un amigo de la
familia haga el recorrido con él su
intención es rescatar a sus padres de
quienes no tienen noticias de más de 20
días
no hago otra cosa que pensar en ellos
sap orilla también acoge a miles de
personas que huyen de otras poblaciones
del sur del país que constantemente son
atacadas como la ciudad de la que viene
a na ella hizo parte de una caravana
improvisada por las autoridades de la
población de gula y paul para evacuar a
mujeres y niños en medio de una noche
donde el asedio se veía inminente tiene
bajo su responsabilidad cuidar de su
madre y sus cinco hijos ellos están
atacando todo no les importa para nada
si hay casas si hay civiles eso no
detiene sus ataques ahora nuestro pueblo
está destruido
actualmente viven en el campus de un
centro educativo que les ha dado refugio
pero les preocupa lo que venga más
adelante no tienen dinero para moverse
hacia lugares más seguros de ucrania y
la guerra se siente cerca cada vez que
suenan las alarmas se dirigen de nuevo
al refugio
y aquí pasamos la mayor parte del día
tras recorrer 80 kilómetros hacia el
norte llegamos a micro
el padre de nítrico lleva la túnica y el
gorro que caracteriza la iglesia
ortodoxa ucraniana pero también las
botas militares que lo identifican como
responsable de dar apoyo al ejército en
esta región
este monumento recuerda una realidad que
parece haber quedado olvidada con la
invasión la guerra en el país comenzó en
2014 en la región de don básico en la
elección de crimea
650 personas han muerto desde entonces
sólo de esta parte del país
todos los muertos en estos años están
aquí al comienzo la mayor parte de ellos
eran personas temporalmente no
identificadas
en las últimas semanas han ido llegando
nuevos fallecidos muchos de ellos son
originarios de otros lugares de ucrania
esta tumba pertenece a un joven de mico
life una ciudad las cercanías del mar
negro que es permanentemente atacada por
los rusos estas personas estos soldados
enterrados aquí fueron conscientemente a
defender nuestra madre de tierra de
rusia de la fascista rusia nikolái este
es el escenario que encontramos aquí la
mitad de la población de 500.000
habitantes ha abandonado la ciudad
a las afueras de la morgue esta familia
llora la muerte del padre de anna que
daba apoyo a la población en una escuela
que fue atacada
estaba en un colegio y una bomba cayó en
el edificio
sólo pudimos encontrarlo a los tres días
solo hoy
los cuerpos que se acumulan en estos
cuartos son la evidencia de la crudeza
de esta guerra
aquí se mezclan militares con civiles
hay misiles y bombas casi todos los
aviones
eugeni nos conduce a su barrio atacado
constantemente por la artillería rusa él
y su familia decidieron desplazarse
hasta otro sector de la ciudad pues para
ellos era imposible continuar viviendo
de esta manera
pero no todos quieren ni pueden
abandonar el lugar
lubbock viene a dar la vuelta a su casa
o indie bible actualmente pasa la mayor
parte del tiempo en el refugio
no tengo ninguna opción para irme del
país no tengo familiares ni amigos en el
extranjero no quiero convertirme en una
molestia para nadie por eso me quedaré a
la espera de mejores tiempos
cientos de personas mayores han quedado
atrapadas en medio de la guerra muchas
de ellas fueron testigos de la segunda
guerra mundial y de la unión soviética
marina nació bajo la cortina de hierro
su padre ha ruso y su madre ucraniana
yo soy rusa y estamos siendo asesinados
por rusia por qué razones no no somos
hermanos y amigos vivimos cerca no
queremos nada malo para ninguno
el balcón el techo de su apartamento
quedaron destruidos así como muchos
otros apartamentos de este complejo
residencial a las afueras cónico live
que estuvo muy cerca de ser tomado por
las tropas rusas
desde entonces este grupo de mujeres
todas mayores y solas prefieren pasar la
mayor parte del tiempo en el sótano
donde se protegen de las bombas
vivimos en permanente tensión vamos a la
farmacia y no hay nada no hay esto ni lo
otro y no somos jóvenes todos tenemos la
atención alta no somos jóvenes
a 130 km al occidente se encuentra
odessa aquí cada día decenas de hombres
y mujeres llenan costales con arena de
las costas cada uno siente que su
responsabilidad aportar a la defensa de
la ciudad
este esfuerzo ha permitido que de
sacrificado y una ciudad certificada las
barricadas construidas con neumáticos y
los erizos de acero han pasado a ser
parte del paisaje el centro histórico de
la ciudad
una de las prioridades de la defensa es
el edificio del teatro de la ópera
símbolo de la ciudad por un gordo o de
esta siempre ha sido una ciudad libre
una ciudad multinacional
también una ciudad donde todos viven en
paz y hermandad pero en caso de amenaza
necesitamos defender nuestra ciudad no
todos vamos a levantarnos y defenderla
es la única vía al corte
la catedral ortodoxa do deza es el
ejemplo de cómo la guerra llegó como un
huracán que borró en minutos la vida que
habían reconstruido después de la caída
de la unión soviética
para muchos de los fieles que se reúnen
en este templo la posición de la iglesia
ortodoxa de moscú que apoya la guerra es
imposible de entender se preguntan por
qué razonó y sus vidas han quedado
quebradas
y para millones de ucranianos destruidas
muchos temen que este solo sea el
comienzo de un camino largo que lleve
solo a más muertes y destrucción
[Música]
pase lo que pase la vida nunca será la
misma en ucrania
[Música]
hasta aquí reporteros en la semana
recuerde que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]